hey guys Pete here today HBO released
what they titled The Watchmen official
trailer so I feel compelled to break
that down it was somewhat unexpected
since we just had the featurette earlier
in the week but more Watchmen is good
Watchmen at this point as far as I'm
concerned there's a lot of stuff we've
already laid eyes on in previous
trailers but there's a ton of new stuff
with a lot of mystery along with some
explanation of what's going on sort of
anyway I think each new bit of news we
pick up interesting details more than we
get any actual answers about the story
that they're trying to tell I'll touch
on this as we go so let's jump in and
break down what's new in this official
Watchmen trailer so things start out
with agent Laurie Blake who we know is
playing Silk Spectre - she's talking to
Regina king who plays Angela a bar she
says people who wear masks are driven by
trauma they're obsessed with justice
because of some injustice they suffered
or go the mask it hides the pain angela
responds i wear the masks to protect
myself to which she says right from the
pain this bit of dialogue makes me
wonder what the bigger conversation
they're having here is about because on
the one hand this sounds like a
description of Rorschach who is dead
obviously but who is also an inspiration
for the seventh cavalry which we learned
is spelled with a k cavalry with a k and
who we once again see are wreaking havoc
for the Tulsa Police we don't know
enough about Angela's backstory yet to
know if what Laurie is saying applies to
her but it's a pretty good guess and we
don't know how Laurie has gotten to be
in the position she's in with the FBI
thirty years have passed since the end
of the comic after all we do know from
Damon Lindelof that this shows going to
examine how we as a society feel about
heroes most notably people who wear
masks in fight crime Angela is one of
those people Laura used to be one of
those people and since she was present
when Ozymandias revealed his plan and
Rorschach met his end is a clear
possibility that she knows things that
the general public does not the cops are
wearing masks to protect their
identities and their families that's not
really confusing they
they made that pretty clear but here's
Laurie a person who was raised amongst
masked adventurers seeming to be against
the idea at the end of the comics she
was still with Dan night aisle two and
they were in hiding more or less and it
seemed like they were probably going to
continue to fight crime
somehow in between then and now she
became an FBI agent like I said who
knows for sure what happened when
nuclear war was averted in the original
comic as far as we know people in the
Watchmen universe believe that the u.s.
was attacked by aliens which was what
Ozymandias plan was we suspect that the
7th cavalry is inspired to wear
Rorschach masks because they've read his
journal
we know from interviews from Damon
Lindelof that they're also white
supremacists so there's this weird
dynamic where they probably know the
truth about the attack on New York City
where as the general public probably
doesn't but they're also bad people the
featurette didn't have much Chief Judge
Crawford in it really it focused more on
Ozymandias and this trailer flips the
other way showing him interacting with
several of the characters Angela tells
him in his office about another cavalry
attack and that she has a guy in her
trunk he tells her to put him in the pod
which he's referring to the Looking
Glass interrogation chamber in there we
hear the guy asked for a lawyer and we
hear lookingglass tell them that they
don't have to give him one because he's
a terrorist this is an interesting
tidbit because we know this is an
alternate reality we know that they
don't have things like the internet and
social media we know that Richard Nixon
was president for five and a half terms
or something like that before Robert
Redford became president to the present
day so we have like 50 years with two
different presidents and it doesn't
sound like that situation has made
things all that much better later we
hear Judd talking directly lookingglass
and he said why would they start this
[ __ ] up again and lookingglass answers
maybe there was something they didn't
want found one of the things that stands
out right away when you watch this
trailer is this Almog that
Angela's drinking out of in Judds office
there's some speculation that the chief
could be dan dreiberg the night out -
it's one of those things though like an
initial reaction when we saw Archie in
the first comic-con trailer was like
yeah that's him
when you think about it though why would
he be in Oklahoma why would he have the
accent it takes a long time to become a
police chief so he had to be embedded
there for a long time and on the police
force for a long time to work his way up
this seems to hint at it and the other
thing that kind of does that is we see
Regina later wearing the night owl
looking glasses but these are like x-ray
specs that are more powerful than
anything we know Dan had in the comic
book so it makes you wonder if he is
still tinkering and this is his
technology along with Archie being a
police vehicle but there's nothing here
that confirms it either way just the owl
makes you think about it some more we
get a shot of the cavalry coming through
a hole in the ground we see them working
with explosives there was a suicide vest
looking thing in the previous trailers
so these guys are definitely doing what
we hear in the voiceover they're trying
to start a war we hear the song running
scared by Roy Orbison and we get a way
better look at Looking Glass inside the
cavalry compound in my featurette video
I mentioned this scene that has this
thing falling through the ceiling with
blue light in the room since there were
church pews and video cameras I wondered
if this could be where the Rorschach's
were standing in front of the crucifix
when they made those videos in this
official trailer we learn that it is
because we get a better look at this
whole compound we hear him say what is
this and the cavalry member responds
this is the only way to show you the
truth so they have him inside their
compound later we see him being
restrained and beat up by them we don't
know where in the season this falls how
it becomes lookingglass that ends up
there but it seems like they were
reaching out to him in one way or the
other it's this curious shot with Angela
and this holographic tree we see lady T
there I call her a lady T it's
rieu which is I believe cow in
Vietnamese but tea is a little bit
easier to say she's a trillionaire
according to the last press release they
did about the characters so we saw this
area that with the futuristic looking
hallway and the last trailer and it
looks like this stuff might be inside
her compound or something related to her
we also see her in the scenes with the
couple again they have a baby the
hourglass we see there can't exactly
tell who she's interviewing but it's in
that same house it's not clear what
she's all about or what she's doing why
she's reaching out to Angela but her
character seems mysterious in a good way
not a bad way some other new clips we
get here are this shot of what is
probably black Wall Street burning
during the Tulsa race riots in 1921 we
know those are gonna be in there there's
a car crash on the side of the road with
a baby being carried away on foot see an
unidentified kid watching butterflies
which feels like a callback to
Ozymandias ha's dome and Antarctica and
the book we get a glimpse of this guy
we've repeatedly seen in front of the
clown at the carnival this is before the
incident went down we see him with his
girlfriend or something along those
lines we have this shot of lorry pulling
a gun out at the funeral scene like it
looks like that funeral scene I can't
say for sure but it seems like it's
connected to that there's a better shot
of Ozymandias riding the horse but I
don't think it tells us any more about
what's happening here he's just riding
by on his horse past the tales of the
black freighter flag see that angela is
running towards this house where we saw
this huge gun battle go down with the
cavalry this shot definitely stands out
we have Laurie sitting in a chair she's
probably restrained it's probably a
seventh Cavalry symbol behind her which
we see a couple of times in this trailer
the outside looks like dr. Manhattan's
mark which is a hydrogen symbol and
there's something like an eyeball
painted inside of it
see Angela using a hammer at home
against somebody she's wearing the same
clothes that she had in the lady tea
scene this seems to just be that same
sequence where we see her defending
herself on the Rorschach's attack course
we see the house
crashing again that's been a repeated
image at this point pencil is in the
crashed car lorry speaks to her after
coming out of that dr. Manhattan looking
thing that we don't really know what it
is she compliments our on a costume
which we can now piece together is a
take on a nun's habit there's a shot
that shows that the beat she wears on
her belt do in fact have a crucifix
attached which I guess would make them a
rosary and it's been out there that her
name was sister Knight but you know it
wasn't apparent to me that the sister
was a reference to the church until the
guy who looking-glasses questioning
refers to her as a nun so I miss that
maybe everybody else got it but I
definitely did not so what do you think
that we learned a lot here the idea of
the potential war between the cops in
the seventh Cavalry seems pretty
straightforward that part of the story I
think we do know kind of a lot about we
know who angela is we know her last
names a bar instead of Abraham which I
got wrong I think everyone got wrong for
a period of time so there is that we
know who a lot of the characters are but
how everything's connected I mean there
is so much stuff jam-packed in these
different trailers that we've seen every
time I see a new one it changes my
thinking of what we can expect to see
throughout this season it's not in a bad
way I'm not saying that it is I'm just
saying that there's a lot of potential
there's a lot of stuff going on theories
are starting to pop up slowly but we
really won't know until we actually see
how they weave this story together how
all these different characters I mean
there's so many different characters and
there's several that we haven't even
seen in any other trailers yet so we've
also got the Louis Gossett jr. character
we did find out what his name was in the
closed captioning it says William Reeves
as his name which doesn't strike any
connections to the source material
necessarily I'm gonna cut it off there I
have some more stuff I want to do in the
next couple weeks related to watchmen so
please give this video a like please
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already go back and check some other
watchmen videos if you haven't seen them
yet I go into a lot more detail about
different things that we've seen thanks
for watching I will talk to you soon